[Music]
my name is Lakshmi Sharma I'm director
of product management for networking at
Google cloud and I have a pleasure of
talking to
I can Solomon he's the chief analyst at
for five and research and we are going
to talk about what hybrid means to
customers and what are their pain points
what are their drivers and what are the
tools that are available for making
their their journey to hybrid are easy
as well as less risky thanks Lakshmi up
kick this off ah technology we're moving
forward so I wanted to touch on the the
morning's keynotes
hopefully most you saw them us was
talking about enterprises need to
transform and some of the challenges
that they're facing of simply because of
market pressures customers demands a
whole set of different pieces that are
really forcing a need to transform and
what we're gonna be talking about today
is really some some statistics about
what's driving some of that but also
some of the capabilities they can help
move that forward technology is not
standing still which is an advantage
generally but it can also be generate a
little bit of risk in terms of concerns
about what's the right path forward and
how to really look at this if we think
about movement to new capabilities and
infrastructure there's tremendous desire
everybody wants to get to a better place
you know whether or not that happens to
be peaches and sunsets new capabilities
in terms of infrastructure cloud
developments whatever that happens to be
there's a lot of push to be able to get
there I think we all as humans want to
be able to move towards a better place
whatever that capability is exactly how
they get there and what they're doing to
make those transitions happen though are
really changing very dramatically in
terms of what enterprises are expecting
today and I wanted to bring up some data
451 has a broad study we have
a 60,000 participant panel that are
looking at transitions and Technology
budgetary intent spending and this is
the data that I'm going to be talking
about today this happens to be from our
voice the enterprise digital pulse about
transitions in on-prem data and the
thing that's the desire part of this is
if you look at today half of the
respondents are identifying that between
3/4 and all of their infrastructure is
on-prem today and about another quarter
have about 1/2 to 3/4 so that's a really
large population that are primarily on
print and probably that's not a surprise
to most of you hopefully not the thing I
think it's interesting from the desire
perspective is you look at where their
expectations about where they want to
get to in two years we're talking about
a pretty dramatic change in terms of
capabilities and both on what's on prem
today and what they expect to be able to
move out again from an aspirational
perspective there's that desire to be
able to get to better infrastructure to
be able to manage your resources better
it's a key part of what some of those
shifts are looking at but it's a pretty
dramatic shift in order to do this
enterprises are really going to need a
whole set of capabilities that they may
not have today and and that's fair like
you know infrastructure like what we
have like at Google like in the
networking space we're talking about
migrating like loads of data like in two
years like the number shows so
capability like you know interconnect
that we have the amount of fiber that we
have put in like any part of the world
so those capabilities may be useful for
those customers right like them because
you are move migrating workloads
migrating data so you would need that
kind of infrastructure support to do
that well and as you start to expand in
areas it's not only just the migration
part it's all those paths to data that
you've got to maintain once you're
starting to move once you're in the
middle of that transition and into
whatever next state you wind up getting
so interconnection winds up being really
critical it's something I think
generally in the move to the early
stages of cloud enterprises really
haven't fully understood precisely how
important that is you know we
we've all dealt with sort of PPN
connections and you know internet access
to be able to manage it but in order to
get enterprise capable performance you
have to have interconnection that that's
gonna be dependable enough to be able to
manage this transition that's
interesting like you know I joined
Google like six months ago and it's very
interesting to hear when people say who
network is seamless and that's exactly
you want customers to see like it's
secure and it's seamless and it's just
it's just connecting you where you want
like you know bringing network to you
bringing cloud to you that's what we do
and cloud infrastructure and and all the
even with geo expansions and all the
expansions that we do in every part of
the world we continue to add more fibers
like you know we have 13 subsequence
that we have we have 125 pop locations
we have loads of dedicated
interconnection and with SLA
so I believe there are no other
companies that offer that kind of resume
for inter connect exactly for the reason
that we kind of believe that if it's
natural has to be there performant and
being able to give you the guarantees
that you need in order to migrate your
workloads in order to migrate your data
so yep well in that seamless piece is
what's important because Enterprise has
traditionally been used to buying
capacity discreetly I'm gonna buy
circuits I'm gonna buy links I'm gonna
buy ports you know all these pieces it's
being able to actually take that
capability and bring it into an
environment that is much easier to use
and easier to consume that helps reduce
risk the other piece that I wanted to
identify that I thought was interesting
about this transition if you look at
what this transition is going to look
like when you think about how that's
gonna be consumed this is a breakdown of
expectations of where enterprises are
how they're expecting to move workloads
and how they're expecting to manage that
movement the top modernised piece there
is really taking a look at expectation
that easy for me to say expecting that
they're gonna take their existing
environments run them on pram and then
start to be able to bring modern
applications so this is mobile apps that
wrap around stuff that's on pram that's
it's a good
first step but it's also again one of
these sort of low-risk first step
enterprise strategies the second that
that's a good step down from that though
but I think it's one of the more
critical pieces is refactoring and shift
being able to take key aspects of those
business applications refactoring what
makes sense basically pulling out some
of those key value functions and being
able to take those into the new
infrastructure
wherever that winds up being the next
beyond that is repurchase and shift
that's just simply you know we're gonna
go take people a little ease that
somebody else has got and we're gonna
we're gonna run it that way we're gonna
manage them simply in that way lift and
shift is one of those pieces that for a
long time I think was was expected to be
the primary way Enterprise would go
forward we just take the application we
pick it up we bring it into cloud
colocation whatever it happens to be but
enterprises have understood that now
that's actually that's a little more
complex than then originally it was
planned to be it is an area though that
we think about what that transition
looks like it can make a lot of sense
for large monolithic functional elements
so we think about things like databases
big pieces that nature those can be
places where that functionality actually
makes sense to migrate closer to where
you expect it to be so sources data
management systems resources the truth
that can be a big transition that can be
useful there
that's an interesting so let's say for
databases would you do you hear that
those databases will still be managed by
the database providers or the IT teams
or where you see the manageability
aspect it's a transition so there's a
big piece of the management of the
operational management that I think of
enterprises could hand that off to a
trusted partner who is managing it it
would make a lot of sense in some cases
they simply want to make sure that all
of that functionality moves over but
they don't want to carry with all of the
management tasks that come with it that
can be a real challenge there's there
are certain things we are doing and you
know some of you if you if you plan to
attend keno
tomorrow and the networking sessions I
would be talking about some of the
managed aspects and how do we bring
manageability at the latency and the
throughput that we offer 12 an
infrastructure so please I would
encourage you to attend the keynote
session tomorrow where you will hear a
lot of things around this well
especially when you get to newer
technologies like transitions into
analytics infrastructure things like
building out Hadoop clusters the
management of any of these pieces can be
a challenge and especially when there
are already difficulties and making sure
that you've got sufficient staff to be
able to manage them that can help to
free up existing staff to be able to
leverage the high value capabilities the
use of the analytics as opposed to
having to spend a lot of time adding
staff to manage the actual operational
pieces you know enterprises want the
functionality so in the refactor and
modernize we talk a lot about micro
services and a lot of our customers come
to us for help for that you know many of
you would know our efforts initio and
Cuba natives and the work that we are
doing in that space we a lot of sessions
coming up around that area too so we
hear a lot of customers might you know
moving towards micro services and we do
do take pride in the fact that we
launched by billions of containers every
week in Google Cloud like you know Cuban
artists came out of book and that's how
we run our infrastructure so how do you
what kind of applications do you see
when you think about modernizations and
do you from a refactoring perspective do
you see customers first refactoring and
trying them on Prem and then moving to
manage let's say cloud or do you expect
to see a management across hybrid cloud
well there's got to be from an
operational perspective you've got to
have some level unified management
across that entire environment I mean
the ideal you know that Sandy Beach the
people are trying to get to is an
equivalent capability across all the
different execution venues that you've
got and to be able to manage that with
the same set of tools across that
environment I think for a lot of
enterprise they expect that to be a
Nirvana they just can't get to because
they've been used to treating
the cloud infrastructure differently
than the way in which they run what
they've got on Prem and and that can
present some real challenges in terms of
your mobility and workload mobility it's
really hard to be able to do that shift
effectively if you've got different
management capabilities you've got to
run and operate differently in terms of
where those capabilities are in terms of
the applications where we see a lot of
those directions really is across the
map there's some vertical variation that
we see by industry but the expectation
to get towards a reaaahhr tected
environment that can better take
advantage is a very strong piece of that
but again that that's some variability
in terms of where that all gets directed
we want to keep this interactive and I
wanted a quick show of hands in terms of
the the lift and shift capabilities for
the folks are here from the enterprise
side of things
how many of you are expecting to be able
to fully refactor any of your key
business apps quick show hands a handful
here and there again probably where are
we about a 18% maybe a little less how
many of you are expecting to be able to
build net new in new infrastructure so
is one of the things that I tend to see
maybe a little stronger you're here at
next you're probably a little more cloud
aware in terms of what your directions
are and where you're headed so another
data point that I thought was
particularly interesting in all of this
is is the shift to what those
infrastructures are actually going to
look like and we start thinking about
what the transitions you know yes people
are getting off Prem but where are they
actually heading and what are those
expectations today again most of the
infrastructure that Enterprise is
working with it is on Prem no big
surprise there there is a reasonable
amount of unprimed cloud capability
today a bit a hosted private cloud not a
lot in terms of sort of what the general
breakdown is a fair amount of use of SAS
and colocation again colocation a lot of
cases we've got folk
we're looking to move systems into
environments where they've got better
connectivity
maybe transitioning out of existing data
center environments a couple big steps
there and of course a reasonable amount
of public cloud use but again if we look
at what that total enterprise picture is
traditional full-blown public cloud for
line of business operations real serious
production applications still relatively
low it's you know sub 10 percent number
is something that we see pretty broadly
my guess is here at next there's
probably a little more use of direct
public cloud capability and whatever
that capacity is the thing though that I
think is is more important is what the
transition looks like and and to be able
to move towards a doubling of
utilization of public cloud capabilities
again is gonna require a significant
amount of transition for enterprise and
I think that's one of the places to your
question about management and/or the
orchestration pieces of this that's
where there's gonna need to be a very
large step in terms of how enterprises
really working with those capabilities
this is very interesting like so
although it says that on Prem IT
infrastructure is going to be half of
what it is today but it's it's
distributed across it seems like based
on the current results enterprise's will
still contain the hierarchies and the
orgs and the roles and the policies and
then they will be distributing it across
so something around policy management
like centralized policy management
keeping how how's it how's the security
like want the control for security going
to be more distributed absolutely well I
think that's the challenge is that ain't
for a lot of organizations once they
start to be able to spread into new
environments it's great to have the
ability to have scaling capacity you
know whatever those drivers are to be
able to get them to those points the
challenge is to be able to take all of
the people and processes that have been
running the organization you know for
however long and actually transition
them into an environment in which they
can take advantage of hybrid capability
there a set of different aspects that
are gonna start to come into play we
already see it today with concerns about
data sovereignty you know what do I put
where
where's the data that's gonna be
actually this app is consuming gonna be
delivered from what do we need to do
with the results you know where can I
run analytics how do i balance all that
stuff that presents a whole set of new
challenges that for most enterprises
they haven't had to deal with before me
so this is a here I will kind of bring
in some other tools that we are offering
and there are two talks around this
today so we had been hearing similar
things that hey we have these identity
management systems and we use this
identity of their proxies and on-prem
and then we go to the cloud then we are
using manage services from let's say
from Google like you know so we are
using your GCS managed services and so
we were coming from plug public side you
are coming from on-prem through private
services how do we how do we manage all
those access right how do we integrate
them into common say policy framework so
that we continue to use the GCP
resources like say which are in V pcs
and we we can have a mapping of the
identities whether it is device identity
or IP range and we can still protect the
data exfiltration which is which may
happen because of you know existing
roles which were able to access the GCSE
buckets so we put in all of that
together in a you know you know in
something called V PC service control so
you can you can bring your identity of
their proxies you can put your policies
right at the V PC level we have like you
know host-based firewalls and things
like that so you you combine both of
them and then you can bring in all the
context like you know over who you are
where you're coming from what time of
the day you are coming from so if it is
distributed kind of access of the
resources things like tools like that an
automation like that becomes very
important right so though those are the
things we had been hearing - so it's
kind of maps to what you just described
well it helps to manage what is that
growing complexity the reality is when
you make that shift
you're now in multiple environments and
and just by nature it's gonna be more
complex what that demands is that you
have tools to be able to leverage that I
got a ghost that keeps shifting these
forward here I guess are you that or
somebody really wants to jump ahead and
the
the enterprise challenge is figuring out
how do you actually live in that world
in which you now have got a whole set of
more distributed environments with
diverse characteristics how do you
manage it in the same way because some
of those big challenges are being able
to take the staff you've got you know in
transitions like this you know I don't
think enterprise is out there expecting
that they're gonna radically increase
the amount of staff they've got to
manage it so they've got to have
simplifications that can help to not
only make the orchestration and
management piece a lot simpler but to
reduce some of that risk in that
transition the point that you're making
about security is right at the top of
those lists in terms of how you manage
and control being able to integrate
identity something that most
organizations have had a hard time with
today gets one of the more powerful
tools and capabilities to have at your
disposal to be able to transform what
was you know a lot of those functional
perimeter based capabilities that
on-prem we're okay and manageable but
once you start to get out into a more
distributed environment can really
create complexities that are hard to get
your hands around from an operational
perspective you've brought up the
product name and the terms like we do
call it service parameter we kind of put
in all the VPC resources and we connect
so yeah and under people say - I was in
India like there was an cloud summit in
India like a few weeks ago and the
points that you touch upon about like
will each organization go and hire these
people like it's not just about either
scientist it's about like just the whole
manageability automation orchestration
and understanding different clouds yeah
so we hear from like you know financials
and retail and across the board in this
region as well as in Asia region that
yes it's so difficult to hire those
people and then kind of train them on
enterprise practices while you're
training well they already bring in kind
of engineering so but we do need to kind
of bring in blend of how organizational
structure and you know and how those
policies in the organizational
environment are done so you know the
tools like being able to kind of apply
you know the educate educate at comes
from understanding IT infrastructure
bringing to the cloud and applying that
back through our tools like hierarchical
policies like our full
projects so so we have been doing that
mix and we had been hearing from
customers it's not easy to just go and
hire those people who can just do same
thing across all the IT organizations so
it kind of ties in to the point that you
said yes it's not easy to just do each
of them for each IT organization that's
why we are trying to build that
experience of understanding enterprise
organization while we are bringing in
technology innovation well it's as
transitions are a huge help staffing has
always been a particular problem but as
special as you start going to new levels
of complexity that can really present
some additional challenges one of the
things I wanted to touch on are some of
the drivers what's actually motivating
people to be able to make these shifts
of an interesting point in some of this
data it used to be I think the original
idea about cloud is people gonna go to
cloud because it was cheap you know
cloud is gonna be the the path to reduce
cost and this is gonna be wonderful well
you know what we've seen over the course
of the last you know this is a
particular study that's been running now
for a little over five years for us is
that reality's starting to finally
appear and people are understanding that
while cost may be a component cost
really shouldn't be the primary driver
and if you look now this is one of the
first times in the study that we're
actually starting to you back get pretty
close to parity with some of the more
important and valuable drivers cost
management can be a huge benefit but
it's one of those things that if you're
just trying to target that alone you
miss out on so many other benefits what
that transition could look like and and
those next three either down there that
are close and grouped fairly closely
enhancing agility improving access to
new technology modernizing the
infrastructure are all some of those
principle drivers that we see about that
the directions of new infrastructure
management the shark will appear but
just not yet not just yet one of the big
challenges in terms of helping
organizations move this forward run
things that we wind up doing from an
analyst perspective is really helping
them align what they're trying to move
towards and
what those capabilities are agility of
course is is a big one being able to
move to scale rapidly being able to
manage some of those shifts in terms of
managing infrastructure with demand
being able to be a little more flexible
in terms of where your resources are how
your infrastructure actually gets built
and what it actually costs you um can be
one of the biggest benefits in terms of
moving to hybrid environments they'll
let you pick and choose and all of this
if you could do like you know yes
reduce IT cost seems to be a little
lower but they still here customers they
do they do want to understand what the
TCO looks like right reducing cost is
one thing but the overall operational
cost right so if you're going from the
m2 containers do I have to use different
tools to have to retrain my organization
so you talked about this construct
called VPC do I have to have a different
paradigm just to go to containers right
if you go from k-8 on-prem to gke or you
know Google's Cuban address engine do I
have to understand different things
about load balancing do I have to know
the VM load balancing be different so so
we do here all of them because like you
said those three things about
modernizing IT infrastructure like how
you're modernizing the infrastructure
all the way from what we know whether it
should be bare metal or VM or container
and then how you will be improving
access which goes back to the you know
I'm used to accessing resources through
private IP are you going to tell me that
my IP address management would be
different right and will it be different
in different regions do I have to
connect different so so we hear all of
that and that becomes TCO for us does
that kind of make sense or like
operationalization and all of it
absolutely I mean again getting back to
people in process so much of what the
transition is to new models whether or
not they happen to be hybrid or simply
revamping the capabilities that you have
already are being able to ensure that
you can actually bring the rest of the
organization along with you and you get
there some of that starts with
development process but a big part of it
it has to be the operational environment
that's going to support it you know if
your dev teams are getting way out ahead
in terms of what their requirements are
but you can't provide that from
operational perspective that's just as
much of a problem as
if you can't build and ship product it's
a challenge I was gonna say from a deaf
perspective I wanted to get another
quick poll how many of you would
identify that your organization's are
doing a DevOps you know CI CD kind of
development process today hands alright
maybe maybe half fish not quite one of
these for our numbers in terms of what
we see broad Enterprise is that it's
still relatively low so again you're all
here at next so you're probably a little
bit ahead of the curve but it's an area
that you're actually getting the
environment to support that transition
of dev teams can be just as much of a
challenge in terms of where this all
winds up moving forward and how it could
be managed to your point you've got to
be able to bring the rest of the
organization along when you get to that
journey so a little bit more challenging
in terms of where that fits now one of
the other things I wanted to talk about
time for the shark as well as desire
there's also a lot of fear and we talked
a little bit about sort of what those
concerns are but quite reasonably when
we think about especially network
infrastructure there's a lot of concern
about what new models can provide and
and what the transition risks are being
able to move to those environments but a
lot like sharks you know this happens to
be a Caribbean reef shark that is really
good for the reef ecosystem they don't
really bother people all that much but
they look pretty scary there's still a
shark and and they're a reasonably good
metaphor for what a lot of these
transitions are because I think a lot of
organizations look at what that
transition is and all they see is change
and change is change when it's not
well-defined when you don't understand
what's gonna get you to that new
environment can be pretty scary for a
good reason because you don't know what
that outcomes gonna look like and
they're more than enough cautionary
tales that are out there people have
seen things go wrong when whatever
happened I I'd make the point that a lot
of us might be tied to not being fully
aware of enough of the network and
interconnected pieces that you gotta
have to be able to bring that together
but
yes leave it up to all of the brothers I
would say that it is because people
don't really understand I mean they
understand the current way of designs
they understand what have been told to
them like you know going from boxes
on-prem to boxes in trout like you know
say hey instead of like I will create
your firewall bird I will keep it like a
box right I will it will be still
throttled because of bandwidth the load
balancer would still be total by the
battery I think that's also because they
continue to be scared because of those
reasons but if they were told that the
shark is now you know maybe like a
gigantic shark and then they don't that
it can't even move it will just stay
globally and we're not really touch you
it will help you like what we have with
you know we we do here all the time
because we are so simple like if people
would have really done the distributed
like kind of lesbian fabric that the way
we have like what we call in Ramadan and
edge not a mission
it's like truly software-defined I know
I am kind of I'm not looking at the
shell because I'm not afraid of it
because nobody when I came to Google
cloud like it's just we just have very
simple things the way they're supposed
to be and that's why people wouldn't be
scared but we want to be able to explain
that how simple it is and it should this
is how it should have been just because
you have global infrastructure just
because you have you know pops
everywhere and fiber everywhere that
that doesn't cause a risk and that
doesn't cost complexities because the
software which is on top it's simple
it's really you know logically
coordinated control plane which is built
to kind of scale to the infrastructure
that we have so people it's just it's so
simple to understand and then if that's
how Sdn were supposed to be right like
you have a logically coordinated control
plane you'll put services on top so if
some services are also build away that
application developers are used to
that's how this company build
infrastructure whether it is that edge
whether you talked about like data
center whether you talk about like your
cloud fabric it's it runs at the scale
so I was talking to somebody yesterday
and and they were asking about the same
thing oh you are so global is it your
infrastructure so people forget that
infrastructure is now
just hardware and edges and routers
infrastructure is capability comes from
the software that we talked about that's
what made cloud possible anything would
have made that smaller in scale then we
then there would be complexity we have
taken all those complexities out you
just just deploy click of a button you
let's say you have global load balancer
you just go to one place and configure
then you go to you know if you want to
bring in your abilities like cloud or
money you just go and configure another
strike of a button whether it is
containers whether it is VM it's really
like single point of configuration
management and distributor to the you
know scale of the world and if if people
would just visualize that I think they
would not be afraid of it well I think
one of the challenges is that you know
we're all humans we see that doing the
same things that we've been doing is the
least risky way to go forward and and I
think especially we start thinking about
our application structures and
interconnection that there's an
expectation that you know if we just
simply take what we had on Prem put it
into new environments in exactly the
same way it's just you that's the safest
way to do it you know it's kind of like
walking on the beach and dress shoes you
you can do that but you're gonna get
sand in your shoes and it's really not
the the best way to go about it put on
flip-flops you know get comfortable
but for enterprises that first sort of
it's that lift and shift piece of we're
gonna take exactly we've got we're gonna
reproduce it you know exactly the same
way it was because we know that works
without thinking about a lot of the
simplifications that can actually start
to pull out some of the complexity
because a lot of the the way in which
applications have been built and a lot
of those structures work really well for
the technologies that were there but
those simplifications that now start to
allow a much easier management better
security better interconnection more
than anything else in new environments
can actually start to help that
transition and can reduce risk in that
process as well that's I think one of
the things that many enterprises tend to
get stuck on is that there's an
expectation that we
simply have to reproduce it exactly the
way we did on print you know I've got a
whole bunch of VLANs I need to map those
same VLAN connections to exactly what
I've got you know wherever I happen to
be despite the complexity of being able
to manage all that those tie-ins and the
configuration complexity that comes with
it it's important to realize that that
maintaining complexity is also a risk
factor and I know and a lot of the
conversations we have with our clients
that that the expectation that we just
keep things the way they are misses out
on an opportunity to actually improve
their risk posture improved their
security reduce errors and configuration
you know everybody's got good statistics
on on how many outages are caused simply
by you know manual error and in some of
those transitions it can be a real
challenge in terms of what really needs
to happen I've used this analogy before
and you know when I worked in previous
job that some cloud providers who
started with keeping the same notion as
in terms of manageability and our
patients at IT and they moved into cloud
they really took the mainframe so clouds
are not for us cloud providers are the
new mainframes of the world right so now
once you're stuck you don't even know
where your storage is and how where are
my policies are managed what kind of
visibility do I have do I can I just use
my manageability and visibility tools
that I have like where is my packet from
you know packets going flow go is like
so all that visibility and manageability
around like my information let's say in
this case V PC or in this case your
resources is if one is not easy to offer
because like it's it's just a new
mainframe for some providers not for us
well and you bring up the point about
operational visibility which is another
critical part you know the move to
virtualization I gave organizations a
lot more visibility in terms of what was
actually happening in the infrastructure
the move to cloud actually increases
that dramatically further but most
organizations don't take advantage of it
in many cases because they're not
actually set up to be able to leverage
greater visibility to be
to take all that telemetry and actually
digest it which actually brings me to
the next point I wanted to identify
which is that there's a dramatic lack of
automation if we think about what
organizations are doing today we've got
to get more automated in ways that are
more sophisticated having lots of
additional telemetry that can give you
information about what's happening is
great but in many cases we keep running
with the same procedures that have got
strong manual dependencies and and this
is particularly true in networking and
it's one of those things that I think is
a you know for me one of those big
transitional opportunities that you can
actually start to do a lot more in terms
of both the capabilities you have the
awareness you have in terms of the
amount of telemetry that's coming out of
those environments and the ways in which
you can put it to work so again simplify
what you're doing day in and day out
that's an interesting piece so we used
to hear and like even before I joined
this company other places hey cloud can
only offer you Altria visibility or it
can give you like you know maybe end of
the day information about all your
applications so to be able to get like
say a non-traditional NetFlow IP fixed
like of information as well as you can
give like a l3 information so a
combination or that was kind of what
what enterprises had been asking for or
like customers had been asking for so in
that space we I mean you know some
products like which we call VPC flow
logs which gives you a combination of
both
so and it can continue to integrate with
your existing CM infrastructure so if
you're used to using certain tools for
just digesting that information and
doing troubleshooting so we have
received a lot of good feedback because
we have been able to understand that yes
you do or like you know as I said like
net flow like information of your IP
flows but at the same time you do want
like where is my where is it coming from
and what my IP address is like the l3
plus application like information so so
we do have some we heard that feedback
and we are bringing up we have brought
up some products like that in that space
well because it's critical to being able
to effectively manage your environment a
lot of organizations tend to sort of
layer on a lot of that monitoring
management capability again
so from networking side and being able
to have the your your environment
actually provided for you again
simplifies what you can do with it how
you can manage it curious in terms of
the environment that's here how many of
you are using more NetFlow meant well
things like network management
capabilities like net flow on other
telemetry to be able to give you
real-time information about how your
environments are operating a lot of
organizations will work with a handful
okay so we're working in they're in good
shape a lot of the capabilities that
next stage environments provide can
really help you get to greater levels of
visibility and also greater some levels
of integration we talked about identity
tie-ins some of those pieces when you
start looking at automation that becomes
an even bigger piece of that environment
where that fits I also want to make sure
that if there any questions that we're
going over any of this we're also happy
to take questions as well
so anything that we've raised or
anything it doesn't fit today all right
well I want to push on to one of the
other pieces about network automation
and what is it that holds people back
network automation is is by its nature
harder than compute and this is a backup
here
and and that's due to the fact that the
impact and the effect of network
automation it's very different than
compute it must be the shark pressing
the button I don't know that if you
think about compute we got really good
at doing compute automation because
computes relatively isolated the
challenge is doing it at scale you've
got to be able to do lots of whatever
that automation piece is but you're
actually only working on small
reasonably atomic pieces of
infrastructure when you actually manage
it network turns that whole thing on its
head networking automation is much more
complicated and I think it's viewed as
more risky because of the fact that you
know network configuration changes much
like managing slides has a much broader
effect you've got you make a network
configuration change and there are a
whole set of potentially connected to
that are tied to it it means that
there's a lot more perceived risk around
Network automation the real paradox to
my mind is that here you've got an
environment in which there is risk but
yet there's still really low automation
and automation would get you to the
point at which you actually can reduce
risk because you're doing fewer manual
operations so it's one of these crazy
situations we think about how you manage
it but there's a significant opportunity
when you move towards new environments
to be able to leverage native
capabilities to actually you know
automate away much of that manual
processes capabilities complexity in
some cases I come from yes Network is
global it's it's there it's seamless and
I'll go back to the example from the
shark like hey this is here is the DNS
here is the CDN provider here is your
API here is your API gateway and it will
divide everybody just talk starts from
because it is hybrid because it is multi
cloud let's just do Federation here
Federation Federation here this will
have different configuration I I feel
like that's also and I will go back to
my kind of example of if if we think
about services as application running on
top of an SDN fabric that's how you know
Sdn or cloud automation was supposed to
be so you're just kind of adding
services as and when you deploy and you
can take those services in a managed
fashion as well right you know some of
the things around each tier for example
they were meant to kind of abstract the
service plane which sits on top of
networking point but if you do not
simplify your network control plane you
won't be able to kind of get the
scalability out of your application so
they both need to continue to go
hand-in-hand and the reason other
reasons but based on my experience are
working with telcos and enterprises has
been there are so many contracts to
write if you talk about I'm going from
so one region or one country to another
country you're talking about interests
you're talking about writing three
months four months spending time on
legal contracts of how not just about
data just about policies right so if if
we could just take that away which which
we do through our global VP sees and you
don't have to really worry about yeah
all of that contracting
hearing and all of that because somebody
has taken care of you for that for you
and you just worry about adding your
application then discovering your
application wherever you are I you know
some of the complexity through the
automation that you talked about does go
away well and I think that's one of the
challenges to automation is that when we
have a really complex environment the
automation task winds up being that much
more challenging you know what you have
to build around it is more complicated
to build if you've got the ability to
simplify it and SDO is a great example
now you've got the ability to leverage
what our built-in capabilities that that
simply remove that complexity how many
of the crowd here are actually using sto
today
it was now officially gone 1.0 but it's
been out there for a while in terms
we've got a handful of folks who are
playing with this deal already the whole
idea about service meshes is one of
again these next steps of
simplifications that can help move you
to environments that are going to be
better suited to hybrid infrastructures
that'll help to abstract the way a lot
of the complexity that you get when
you're moving towards environments that
give you a lot of choice and a lot of
flexibility in terms of where you're
headed so making transition so it's not
really the network is because network is
just there so the transition that
happens if through that transition
journey if you can keep the paradigm say
maybe like an the reduce the toil with
the automation and the tools and just
allow your customers or your enterprises
to not just develop faster but continue
to update faster do I hear a lot of
numbers about hey we have you can write
like 2000 deployments in a day but in
what if you have to
vii want to bring in like a lot of
features every day I want to make sure
that my automation and orchestration
continue to support that development
upgrades needs to be faster - right
absolutely well it to get to that level
of speed you've got to simplify what
your operational capabilities are you
can't have complicated systems that are
running it so again a great way to be
able to manage that and work that
transition one of the other points
wanted to bring up and this is actually
the
the last slide in terms of what some of
the the data is that I've got up here
and this is one of the ones that I think
concerns me most about this most recent
study this is something that came out of
the field just a couple months ago which
is the budget that's typically being
allocated if we take a look at what's
happening in terms of expectation of
spending I think right now a lot of the
fear about what transitions and risk are
presenting to people are actually
holding back expectations of spending
this is something that from the value to
organizations is something that you've
got to be willing to be able to budget
to be able to make this transition
because there are going to be shifts in
terms of where that fits if we think
about you know what the expectation is
terms of spending on transformation and
investment in the infrastructure and how
that actually gets transitioned these
are things that you know you've got a
relatively small number that are looking
at spending significantly enough to be
able to get to the infrastructure
support that's going to need them that
they're gonna need to be able to get
there and I think a lot of this winds up
being driven by concerns that I don't
want to invest in something that I see
is risky and and it's good but the
challenge there is then that that holds
off what actually are the capabilities
that are gonna enable you to get to
where you need to be mm-hmm and and and
that presents some difficulties this is
something where you don't have to go all
in in terms of transformation but you do
need to make the effort to be able to to
get to a point at which you can operate
more efficiently and you can leverage a
lot of these capabilities so it's not
just so this specific slide is about
like how much budget on the
transformation site but the budget could
still be spent on the operational side
so we still have kind of you can still
go and help out by operationalizing
keeping like you know extending in a
seamless way and giving all the tools so
but that budget still exists not getting
rid of anything but to get there I think
the the thing that I think both Laxmi
and I have been have been really trying
to reinforce is that the fundamental
aspect of this is that you've got to get
to a point at which you can be more
efficient being able to move towards new
environments
is powerful they're a tremendous set of
things that it helps to bring to the way
in which the organization can
potentially operate but it's something
where you've got to be able to to ensure
that the people and processes are
supported with capabilities underneath
this as well those simplify operations
like we and with tools like Cuba NATO's
engine that we support in automation
automation and 2n so all the work that
is happening in SEO and managing
services across so that as well as like
the combination that I talked about like
we PC Service control where you
integrate all the way from edge to the
core through identity all the way to
your EPC resources and manage services
and managing all those abstractions
around it so seems like you know so we
have in networking we have a lot of good
tools and then there are lot of talks
there please you know go today there are
sessions around end-to-end security from
edge to data center or edge to coal and
how do we connect that through the
identity where proxies and then we talk
about logical Association and
application grouping like we have a lot
of products around application delivery
like you know the load balancer global
load balancer and cloud armors a lot of
things around the application grouping
as well as the security aspects rather
and it's really managed through the
similar abstractions and I would rather
say that infrastructure that is built
over years so one is one is from how do
you access that but at the same time for
us our infrastructure is designed that
way too so if you talk about like things
coming from egress they hit our you know
GFE and which is kind of supports our
global load balancer which supports like
in a products like cloud or base so we
are organized or infrastructure wise
also we are designed that way and we do
have software that would substraction on
top and we do continue to kind of make
investment through the open source work
and yeah open source supports hybrid and
multi-cloud to well and that can smooth
that path for enterprises to be able to
make that transition and to be able to
get to that point it's important to
think about not only the automation
pieces but how that actually affects
operation as a whole
and to your point it's simplifying all
those operations being able to go bring
that together with a set of tools that
enterprises can typically consume and
the ability to be able to bring that all
in ways that that leverage hybrid
infrastructure can help to make that
transition as painless as possible but
more importantly to reduce risk in that
transition at the same time and hybrid
does mean that multi cloud as well right
so we can help customers go from one
cloud to another analyst we've got very
specific definitions for some things but
the reality is hybrid environments are
simply a matter of you know multiple
clouds multiple capabilities but the
important thing is to understand how
you're gonna how you're going to run
that environment and operationalize the
points that you're identifying are big
pieces of making that transition simple
from an enterprise perspective and I
think you were mentioning that this
afternoon there's also going to be a
little bit of yes some more surprises in
the networking track later on today
that's correct
so there is a session to see this
afternoon coming up on how there is how
we are defining some constructs and
networking where you would be able to
leverage them and get like native load
balancing in a hybrid way and when I say
hybrid to me hybrid is like the point
that I touched upon it's multi cloud and
hybrid across infrastructure like load
that doing load balancing the highest
latency and the best bandwidth
optimization for VMs as well as for
containers so so there are some you know
things we are going to launch and we are
going to talk about to make this very
simple operationally same regardless of
what infrastructure in what location do
you choose and bringing all the power of
like what we talked about like CDN and
you know TLS support from multiple
certificates and things that we have
been doing in the face of global load
balancing and we will bring all of that
to support multi cloud and hybrid so if
if you you know plan to attend or want
to hear about that please refer to some
of our Cuban ettus sessions and they
will be
and as well as like end-to-end security
sessions so with that thank you so much
and thank you everybody for attending if
you have some questions there you know
we'll be around for a few minutes here
so with that thank you again thanks a
lot thank you
[Music]